[Applause]
so what are the stakes
why are you doing what you're doing and
why is that important
where would you like to move also we
have seen a range of possibilities why
am i doing what I'm doing or by the way
when I think I so if there's working um
okay I think I do what I do because if I
don't do it then I'm miserable so it's
it's I don't know probably a scientist
would tell me it's not biological but
it's just a kind of innate sensation
hüseyin you talked about kind of a
musician and expressing your the sense
of the world vibration in a way and i
think that you know the creative process
for me in my experience i don't really
have an idea of what it's going to be
like in the end and it's more just like
steering the intuitive path towards
something which is very uncertain but
it's there's something that's pushing
you towards that I've seen it stop I
guess I well I got into biology because
I was like this is awesome
there's the idea that biology grows and
is inside of us doing all these amazing
things at all of these different scales
and all these different levels and it's
all connected in these beautiful ways
like biology is really inspires me every
day why I do what I do with artists and
being on panels like this is because I
was really tired of hearing other people
talking about what the future was going
to be and it didn't fit it didn't sound
like it didn't match what I thought or
what I was feeling or what I was seeing
about what was special or interesting
about biology or what was what will felt
real to me and so yeah basically I was
tired of all the jerks having
having their way I wanted success we
have be able to yeah imagine something -
and be part of that fashion I think yeah
so I think that in my work as an
anthropologist both the project that I
presented to you about today and my
prior work which was about slot machine
addiction actually which seems quite
different but is another sort of human
machine I mean in a sense the slot
machine is sort of like a wearable
technology right and it is another sort
of mediation of experience and
modulation of effect and being in the
world and it's one in which the goal of
the gambler and the casino is to exit
the world and go into what gamblers call
this sort of machine zone where time
space and even a sense of self falls
away and I was fascinated by this next
project on tracking technology because
it seemed to me similar but different so
there's a similar kind of anxiety about
being a self in the world and
nervousness and need for modulation but
there's a desire to stay in the game so
to speak in time-space and the world but
a desire to have help doing that and
agency is in trouble in a similar way in
both projects and that's really the
theme that in my work drives me that I
think is so important across the board
is that this idea of individual agency
that we see as a problem that we don't
have it but then sometimes it's a
problem when we do have it and I feel
like we're caught often in public and
academic conversations you mentioned Big
Brother
I talked today about little mother and
on both sides you can kind of critique
you know who's taking away our agency
how do we protect our agency and we fall
into these conversations about
empowerment and privacy versus the Big
Brother and the sort of constraints and
surveillance and I'm trying to kind of
get beyond that and show that you know
prep the whole like idea of agency and
privacy is founded on certain kind of
capitalist notions of property and you
can you can ex
these things and take them back to the
very problems that are that are creating
the troubles we have in the first place
so I want to put that aside people
always think this tracking stuff in
wearable technology they want to go
right to privacy and control and
empowerment and autonomy and I want to
say hold on that's a great conversation
lots of people are having it let's talk
about our own relationships to our
bodies and to the world and to each
other
that maybe will illuminate other ways in
which we are human and not human as as
Lela put it in the opening comments I
know that we have an agency one of my
favorite topics to say we talked a lot
about politics yesterday and your work
is political in so many ways but still
how do you manage to be not ready with
the politics how do you engage the
political comment and click it but yet
your work is also so point taken you
Tamara done I wonder you know what are
the kind of challenges that you face in
your field on these issues well one of
the reasons why I think I became a
designer was because I wanted to
understand the world I guess and my work
should become may be a catalyst for
understanding and then the and I'm going
to come back to your question and then I
think it was looking at the body as my
as my tool because I felt that
everything we do in the world is a
amplification of the body and the way
the body is made we look at the systems
we create if you look at the buildings
we build vehicles or build programming
even I think there is somehow this this
idea of how we are made ourselves kind
of innately and instinctively amplified
and everything we do so there is that
realization for me and then the third
point is communication and the
satisfaction of communication I think
that when we communicate and it's
reciprocal I guess it's the ultimate
feeling of good let's say and then all
these other other things infiltrate like
I think Paul
pigs you know are you think of them
differently depending on where you're
from what you'd experience in an arm
from part of the world where different
cultures collide you know I'm very mixed
background and I guess and people's knew
of me with the name Hussein would be
different because of you know what they
might think but actually I didn't even
think of my name is Hussein until 9/11 I
never thought of it I never thought that
I came from a Muslim background or
anything you know came from a very
secular background so then you get
reduced to what people you know how they
perceive you but I chose to do is
actually I guess people's like cliche
understanding of what one should think
or be but I always felt for me that I
was like a detached observer or behavior
so I am looking at politics in a sort of
detached manner but at the same time
because I'm from a certain background it
filters through inevitably so it's sort
of space in between I would say you
mentioned on several occasions that you
know you work with this idea of being an
immigrant in different disciplines and
and I will tell your moral code
Renaissance men and we have also for
instance women here with all the
different talents and crossing over the
disciplines and collaborating in a
number of people one of this
intersection of art science culture and
technology how does that work for all of
you will say how do you harvest that
energy between these beings and what
makes really interesting for me and I
have described myself as a immigrant
between different disciplines and it
gives me freedom and I think a multi
lateral way of thinking that I find more
enriching so yes is freedom for me
personally and also being able to engage
with all different kinds of worlds and
ways of thinking because then I think if
you do think
cross-disciplinary or a cross-cultural
way I feel that the work can get it gets
more exciting and more stimulating
personally I agree I think that the
Vienna's idea of freedom and being able
to see beyond yourself I think certainly
for me when I was a student and very
very narrowly focused in the molecular
scale I was thinking about a particular
piece of a particular enzyme all day
long and like for the purpose of saving
the world by making biofuels I certainly
like yeah was was you couldn't see the
forest for the trees and being able to
think interest in an interdisciplinary
anyway interdisciplinary way and talk to
people who are asking questions about
similar topics and engaging with this
idea of where are the problems how do we
solve problems with technology and
design how do we understand the
intersections of politics and culture
within science and technology that
helped me get outside of that and start
to see how all these things were
connected how technology was really
happening you have questions to each
other I would encourage the other ones
I'm reading here the audience has some
really crunchy questions if you would
like to hear them so I'll throw a couple
of them in the pool so why the white
female idealized or the seemingly the
only representation presented here it
says and then like like good thing how
has central st. mark and shaped your
career and do you believe you would be
where you are without that exposure it's
a really important question actually
because I just so I went to Central said
Martin which was an art school where
fashion happened to be a department in
it so that meant that already talking
about this kind of cross-disciplinary
way of living and learning I was
engaging with people from sculpture from
fine arts and photography and I didn't
really go to a fashion school so this
was this
really important point and yes my work
wouldn't be what it would it wouldn't be
busy or hadn't gone to set markings but
definitely I think also being in a very
multicultural environment you know
everybody was from somewhere else I
think that's a very important way to
grow and I was so happy yesterday that
at MIT is felt very multinational and
multicultural and I think to expose
yourself to things that are very
different to you it's very important and
very you know I think that's how you
grow and not to hang out with people
that are like you what is relevant to
the first question I did was a good
observation a second also related to
that maybe we can connect them together
how how has thinking about the feminine
or about the female body in particular
being especially generative for imaging
a different viable a better future and
so and then we have the idealized female
body the only representation yes so I
think it's a good there it's connected
right I think why is imagining the
female and feminine important for
thinking about different things are
better future I think that's because so
much of the like science fiction
imagining of the future is for men man
has what male characters or like the via
spaceships were designed at first you
know like Apollo whatever is like they
were didn't make them for women it was
like impossible technologically to make
them to fit women right and so like so
even just imagining a woman in space
like made NASA go crazy and it's really
interesting about like thinking about
all the variation and body is in general
and it's important for thinking about
the future
I think the yeah how it ties to like the
representation of race and the images I
think it's a good question and I was
English that's something that should
challenge all of us to think about how
we're thinking and doing and making
these images because I think it was yeah
who we see and how we see ourselves as
part of these futures and images is
how we make the future there's one more
maybe policia natasha to help answer
natasha helped us to see technologies as
ethical modulators the flashy visceral
technologies lucy and christina
envisioning also for cordial
technologies I could just interpret a
little there is Sukkos work on care of
the self on his later work going back to
Greece and looking at the Stoics and
other groups who really cared about
living a flourishing life and tracked
themselves in many ways so you know is
this theme of self-care and living a
good life is what I think that question
is asking about and how you guys would
see that in your vision of technology I
didn't show some behind the scenes
images but generally I start
experimenting on my body so I've been
known to wrap myself in membranes with a
vacuum cleaner and potentially can
suffocate myself so it always starts
with my body and then works out from
there
and if I'm making a film in terms of
self care which is maybe going off the
track but if I'm making a film then I'm
maybe doing some kind of crazy might I
at the same time to balance out the the
making process so I think you know the
state of mind when we are giving birth
to these ideas of science and technology
is really important and it goes back to
you know being vulnerable and the
mindset of taking a risk and not really
knowing I don't know if I've answered
that call so just dry out one aspect I
was taken by this kind of epistle Larry
you know Australia Cambridge exchange
that you had in a critical part of self
care for through colon this and for for
the Greeks and many other groups was the
social exchange and that self care had
to do with being a good citizen in a
polis and often when you took track of
yourself at the end of a day
that wasn't enough you had to share it
with another citizen to hold yourself
accountable so I think that the two of
you in your very process we're not in
this sort of isolation Institute you
where you are communicating fun Olivia
Buffalo sending regards okay so one last
question if you could say Husain you're
driving creative force is not active
rather than a technology specifically
why do you think you have gravitates
while you were gravitate towards
technology as material so often why do I
because I think that the only things you
can do in this world right now that is
new is wire technology because in my
field everything has been done already
fashion is a self-perpetuating cycle and
I genuinely believe that the only thing
that is that can be done this new is
wire technology but I use technology as
a tool I don't do it for the sake of it
and yes and also just generally ideas
are being kind of coming up is
enhancement and I can improve human
experience improve confidence you know
empower the body all these things I
guess you know I gravitate to all these
things naturally and and I think that
should be the role of technologies to I
guess improve our lives well on that
note isn't that happy aspiring notes I
would like to thank all of you and
thanked cast for continuing this
fantastic conference well let me thank
all of you and may I say that we're
going to take a few minutes to reset the
stage so please feel to be free to
stretch but don't go too far because
we're going to have a wonderful
performance by my adviser to close out
today and then they'll be followed by a
reception downstairs so take a few
minutes mill the priest I'll lead will
be ready in a few minutes
[Applause]
[Music]